padhu tom from western australia if
quantum entanglement or quantum
spookiness can allow us to transmit
information instantaneously that is
faster than the speed of light how do
you think this could dare I say it
change the world Tom I love you Matt
thanks for the tip of the hat there the
turn of phrase
well quantum entanglement change the
world if this turns out to be a real
thing well or if we can take advantage
of it
seems to be the first thing that will
change is computing we'll be able to
make computers that work extraordinarily
fast but this it carries with it for me
this belief that we'll be able to go
back in time that we'll be able to
harness energy somehow from black holes
and other Astrophysical phenomenon that
we observe in the cosmos but not so
readily here on earth
we'll see Tom in Western Australia maybe
you'll be the physicist that figures
quantum entanglement out at its next
level and create practical applications
but for now I'm not I'm not counting on
it to change the world however I am
counting on all of us
to continue to explore to continue to
build particle accelerators to continue
to observe the cosmos to continue to
fund basic research so we will make
discoveries about quantum mechanics and
the nature of nature and subatomic
particles you were alive when the Higgs
boson was proven to exist you were alive
when Italian researchers thought they
had found a phenomenon that was faster
than light but it wasn't but it has led
to further explorations and so now
people wonder about the next thing in
subatomic in particle physics below the
Higgs boson and if they
is discovered who knows where it'll lead
but it is only through basic research
that we will learn about the
extraordinarily small and the
extraordinarily huge fabulous question
tom carry on
lead the world